okay so my picture is of my grandma she
had just got put into the hospital with
stage four cancer and so she had to have
a balloon of her nose to help her
breathe butter and we all have this
picture of my whole family as our
screensaver to say if she can have that
happen and still have her tongue stick
out then any crappy day can be a good
one this photo I chose it because I
recently got out of depression and my
friend got me into two freediving and
how I look at freediving I look at it
like we always looked at my depression
my buddy and I Danny we all do that my
depression like you pick up that rock
every day you know you wake up you can
choose to be like man this sucks you
know my life sucks for more we all got
problems we all got like stresses and
things like that but when I was down
there at the bottom lift lifting up a
rock you know you can easily you know
what I'm going to stay here let the rock
keep me down and I drowned that's it
game over but no you you can put that
rock aside and come up you know choose
to live choose to see the day in a whole
new light you know it's actually just a
reflection a mirror I have in my bedroom
and I saw it and immediately I took a
picture of it because I think it
captures what I think the soul would
look like like how colorful and full of
energy
I really believe you know all that stuff
so when I saw it was like well there's
like a slight chance my soul would look
like this when I was in vacation in Las
Vegas I choose to visit the Grand Canyon
it was a something I really wanted to do
because it's a an escape I really want
to discover and when we arrived after
more than six hours of bus we see we saw
the landscape which wasn't what I wanted
to see because actually we couldn't see
anything
it's a sad part of that picture but a
good aspect of this one is I met a very
nice person who a stranger who now is
one of my really good friends so that's
part of it I like it because like in
everything in life you have a good
aspect and I'm and abandoned it so that
be to remind me that my favorite photo
is my screensaver and it's my wife and
my daughter on her 16th birthday right
there that's in our backyard and it's my
favorite photo because my daughter looks
so much like my wife which makes me
really happy yeah I didn't know someone
was taking this picture of me and I'm
just like cheesing super big and I think
whenever I look at it I look really
happy and I picture and without like a
forced form of happiness or like an
edited version of it it's just like
someone caught me slipping and she's in
really big and I think of like how
infrequent that smile is in like my
day-to-day and so having a concrete
version of it is really cool so I have a
brother who is autistic and he suffers
from a lot of like body image issues and
so he doesn't really let us take
pictures of him we actually like don't
have any pictures of him smiling because
whenever we ask him to pose for a photo
he's like not smiling I was like just
messing with him and it's like the only
picture I have of him and I together
where he's smiling so I want you to look
at the photo and tell me how it makes
you feel
makes me think of like how happy my
brother makes me smile is just like it's
really nice to see because I don't get
to see it that often
this photo means a lot to me growing up
I would always tell my friends that I
don't have any pictures of me when I was
a baby until I went back to Jamaica few
years ago and I saw that my grandma had
all these photos of me when I was
younger and I saw this picture of my dad
holding me when I was a little girl my
mom's very beautiful and she always had
a lot of men that chased after her but
what made my dad stand out was he loved
my brother as if he was his own and just
that love that he had for kids I just
got to see it in the photo like that's
how he loved me when I was a little girl
so yeah I love that picture
man Chico State so we were talking for
months and she graduated and I was still
in school and we weren't sure if we
wanna do the distance thing so one day I
told her I was like hey I got a flight
to San Diego and we come down to see you
I got some news to tell you she's like
okay so I came down and on that day I
told her my girlfriend it's funny
because today's actual are seven months
together yeah that picture was seven
months today
[Music]
the photo is when I first asked her out
it was during Tiger say I'm only allowed
one of my favorite pigs I chose this
photo because it's a picture of all my
friends from work when I got to work I
didn't I didn't really think I was gonna
make any friends I just worked with a
relative me going to work and not making
friends but I came out not only with
friends or with a new family we took
pictures during our friend to give you
that we had this year or last year so
that's why I chose his picture I
obviously would if you guys have this
many new friends and I do so makes you
very happy I chose that photo only
because it represents my life from
Mexico and the state's only because my
dad was deported so it's basically my
whole life change and reason why I moved
out to San Diego cuz it's closer to
Mexico I took the photo that I'm gonna
be showing you guys it's the border from
Tijuana and San Ysidro well it's
actually a meaningful experience because
I've been in the migrant camp of Samoas
for an internship last summer so I was
basically playing with the children
inside of the camp it was quite sad when
you see it at first because you see that
they are garbage everywhere the clothes
that they are wearing are all broken
that behind it I think that there is a
powerful message that no matter what
life just continues because yes they are
still playing and in all of this that
was going around kids were just kids my
father is of one of my best friends who
actually passed away just over a year
ago and it's of hair on her second
birthday and it's just like a really
special memory and just sort of like a
special moment I guess unfortunately
Hannah
after moving away suffered a range of
bullying and
those sorts of issues and actually took
her own life which was an absolutely
devastating moment because the person
that she was when she did take her own
life was a very different person to the
henna that I grew up with so this photo
was taken right as I was crowned as
monsieur belinda and it was the moment
that I realized that I am the girl
that's going to represent my city and it
was the moment I realized that I'm doing
it for all the other brown girls in the
audience watching and are motivated and
inspired we've lived in our house for
about 15 years and we have squirrels in
the neighborhood and I have gotten in
the habit of feeding the squirrels and
so they come up on our porch and it's
gotten to the point now where they'll
come up you know right up to our kitchen
window and tap on the window and so you
know we I like them and they seem to
like living near us I think they
consider our porch you know so that's
what you know so I have a lot of
pictures of squirrels but that one in
particular is pretty typical of a
Saturday morning where they'll come up
to the window waiting for breakfast when
they see us in their evenings yeah my
favorite photo is basically a photo of
me when I was a baby and it was after I
got home I guess from the hospital and
it's a picture of my dad looking at me
and smiling and I just thought that was
really sweet because I'd be like
we don't really express that much
emotion in my family and I just thought
it was very loving and I'd like my mom I
feel like she looks like how I look like
now so that's pretty cool well in this
photo this is my first car accident my
freshman year of college and really it
just looking back at it I mean first it
traumatized me but now now that I see it
it reminds me that one
I should never take life for granted and
to that Sandi Aegon's don't know how to
drive in the rain I'm from San Diego
yeah I was just at the beach it was me
my dog my parents we just let the dog
run around typical dogs to pick up the
poop that sort of thing
my dog is one of my best friends so
that's why it's my favorite photo I
could have easily chosen a meme or
something like that but my dog deserves
the number one spot sometimes he can be
a role model
he likes everyone and anyone doesn't
matter if they're bad or mean and
whatever he just likes him regardless so
I like that about him he's really cute
fluffy he doesn't shed he does funny
things he's a golden doodle he's never
like let me down or anything like
whenever I see him I smile so that's why
he's my favorite person I chose this
photo cuz it's my it's my girlfriend's
plushie she had this story where she was
washing her plushie and she like put it
sat on her bed and like the face it's
making is like so adorable that I just
say okay you can just pretend it to me
so I sort of self insert myself into
that plushie so like whenever I feel
like sad or happy because of like the
weird face he's making like it's just
he's just a 1 1 all fix all for like all
of my emotions like it's like I'll be
waiting for you this is moving for our
date we waited let me set up the
restaurant so it's just one of my photo
was a day of my mom's wedding
it was beautiful chaos and I think what
I loved about it was I was able to bake
my mother's wedding cake my cake line is
called dumb expressions patisserie well
this is my little cousin and it's
meaningful just because it's her she has
this like vibrancy for life and she has
rheumatoid arthritis
she's ten so it's like a reminder that I
can't take myself sir seriously you know
like she's literally in pain more days
than most people are and she's still a
happy kid you know that's my baby right
there
hi everyone thanks for watching another
episode basically I just want to say
welcome to the new subscribers and to
the subscribers who have been with me
for a while I want to thank you for
constantly supporting my channel that's
pretty much it thank you guys again for
everything and I'll see you next week